okay, so yesterday I did a story about how
youtube is increasingly the,
uh, destroying independent news and politics
channels. And I explained to you that youtube
is increasingly prioritizing basically just
what makes them money by keeping advertisers
happy. And since September, that has not been
independent content like ours. It's been instead
this legacy corporate content and I went through
yesterday in much more detailed than I will
do today. How our portion of videos that come
from, what is the suggested video feed on
Youtube. It's an algorithm that says, oh,
you watched this piece of video. Here's other
stuff you might like. We used to get a third
of our views from that suggested video algorithm
that has fallen basically by 50% to under
17% so far in June. This maybe it seems like
a lot, maybe it doesn't. But as I said yesterday,
this is about half of what we were once getting
from this algorithm. And this decline started
right after Youtube announced that in an effort
to crack down on fake news, which may well
be a good faith effort, they are going to
back what they consider authoritative sources.
And that has coincided coincidence, right?
With the decline from 33% of our views coming
from the suggested view, uh, of, uh, sources
to under 17%. And this is a massive blow to
our revenue because it represents a lot of
views. I mentioned yesterday and I'm just
getting you up to speed before I give you
the new info about how this is much worse
than even I thought in December we got three
and a half million views just from the suggested
video feed in June, we will be lucky to get
a million and a half views. That's a 2 million
view short fall, which is a huge revenue shortfall.
Very, very big. I can't tell you how much
revenue that is, but if you Google, uh, Youtube,
uh, CPMs, you could probably calculate it
for yourselves. And I received a flood of
emails yesterday telling me just how bad it
is and it's actually even worse than I thought.
I want to remind you, Alexander wrote to me
last week or the week before and he told me
something that's really odd, which was that
he had never watched anything by Joe Rogan
on Youtube before and then I was on Joe Rogan's
program on June 5th and Alexander watched
one video on Joe Rogan's channel, my interview
with Joe, and the next day every single recommended
video was a Joe Rogan video. Despite Alexander
having watched my content on youtube for years
and having been previously recommended my
content on Youtube, I now have even more data
points and it's really bad. A lot of people
wrote to me with basically some version of
this email that Lisa wrote to me. Lisa wrote
to me yesterday and said, Hey, David, just
listened to the podcast where you spoke about
the new algorithm for Youtube. I noticed last
week that you were no longer on my homepage
of youtube and I had to search for you.
I have a subscription. So you did turn up
on the subscription page. I have also noticed
that the majority report Kyle Kalinsky and
other shows I watch are no longer on my home
page. Despite me having subscriptions for
a long time. My homepage is now filled with
many things I don't watch or subscribe to
mainly balanced between parakeets. I don't
even know what that is. And Cardi B, I'm so
sorry that this is affecting your show financially.
I love your show. Keep up the good work. Um,
sadly, dozens, dozens of emails like this
and I, as I've said before, we know what the
solution is here. We've got a disconnect.
The programming from being dependent on ad
revenue, that that's the solution. I, I've
said before, I estimate under 1% of my audience
funds the show directly through membership.
If we can get from under 1% to 2%, we're in
fantastic shape.
If we can get to 3% of our audience supporting
us directly, we have no more problems. Period.
I mean that's the, we're talking about such
small percentages that going from 0.8% to
2% or 0.8% to 3% is a game changer. So I believe
this has to be a wakeup call. It doesn't have
to be this show. Okay. What I'm telling you
is if there are programs that you like that
you want to see remain independent that you
want to see producing the content they believe
should be produced, not what is going to be
monetized by youtube or other arbitrary algorithms.
We need to support those shows directly if
we can afford to do so with my program, the
way to do that is it joined pacman.com okay.
We have normal prices that I believe are very
reasonable with a pay what you can afford
model starting at $6 a month or $60 per year.
However, I understand that's a lot of money
for many people in the audience and that's
okay. We have discounts available. I mean
it's just take the discount if you want it.
If you apply the coupon code, this is 2020
when you sign up, any membership is reduced
by 40% okay? I'm going to say something even
further today. There is an old coupon code
which we very briefly promoted, which we haven't
been promoting, but because the situation
is just so important right now, I'm going
to give it out today. If you want a 50% discount,
okay? Which will get you down to $3 a month
or $30 a year. $30 a year is like to 80 a
month, okay? The coupon code half 19 h a l
f one nine will drop any membership by 50%
we're not talking about a lot of money, but
this is the way that we fix this problem.
It's, it's the way, it's the most direct way
and that's why I'm asking for your support.
Please share this video using the share button
on youtube because it's really important to
get news of what's going on to as many people
as possible and yes, I know people are saying,
Hey David, did you hear about ECS, Youtuber
who seeing the same thing? Who's on the right,
maybe. Did you hear about ECS, youtuber on
the Awai Youtube or on the left who is seeing
the same thing? Yes, I'm in touch with a lot
of those folks and we are talking about this
a lot. There's no question about it.